wanting to be an entrepreneur versus
being an entrepreneur two very different
things
you want to be an entrepreneur start
acting like one meaning start a business
start selling things both will work 1982
running around the neighborhood ripping
out flowers forcing my friends when they
said let's play basketball to stand
behind a lemonade stand
this wasn't something I read about it
was always there a lot of people want to
become entrepreneurs and are really
number two or three or four operators if
you have a full-time job you're not an
entrepreneur you may have
entrepreneurial tendencies but when you
weren't entrepreneur you can't believe
having a job and it's okay for you to
have an entrepreneurial hobby you want
to be a Pepsi or eBay selling stuff on
the side if you're ready and willing to
take a job then you have entrepreneurial
tendencies entrepreneurial tendencies
hobbies are amazing that's probably one
of the great hobbies to have so many
operators and create apps and artists
out there that are being forced by all
the media right now if they want to be
an entrepreneur need to take a step back
and really make a decision say okay I'm
an artist but I'm gonna do some
entrepreneurial stuff on the side
instead of becoming an entrepreneur and
spending three four five six years down
a rabbit hole not honing in your skill
that comes natural and trying to become
something that is the trend of the
moment